cells are the smallest living units of
an organism
all cells have three things in common no
matter what type of cell they are
all cells have a cell membrane
which separates the inside of the cell
from its environment
cytoplasm which is a jelly-like fluid
and dna which is the cell's genetic
material
there are two broad categories of cells
the first category is eukaryotic cells
they have organelles which include the
nucleus and other special parts
eukaryotic cells are more advanced
complex cells such as those found in
plants and animals
the second category is prokaryotic cells
they don't have a nucleus or
membrane-enclosed organelles they do
have genetic material but it's not
contained within a nucleus
prokaryotic cells are always one cell or
unicellular organisms such as bacteria
so what are organelles
organelle means little
organ
organelles are the specialized parts of
a cell that have unique jobs to perform
let's start with the nucleus the control
center of the cell
the nucleus contains dna or genetic
material
dna dictates what the cell is going to
do and how it's going to do it
chromatin is the tangled spread out form
of dna found inside the nuclear membrane
when a cell is ready to divide dna
condenses into structures known as
chromosomes
the nucleus also contains a nucleolus
which is a structure where ribosomes are
made
[Music]
after ribosomes leave the nucleus they
will have the important job of
synthesizing or making proteins
outside the nucleus the ribosomes and
the rest of the organelles float around
in cytoplasm which is the jelly-like
substance
ribosomes may wander freely within the
cytoplasm
or attach to the endoplasmic reticulum
sometimes abbreviated as er
there are two types of er
rough er has ribosomes attached to it
and smooth er doesn't have ribosomes
attached to it
[Music]
the endoplasmic reticulum is a
membrane-enclosed passageway for
transporting materials such as the
proteins synthesized by ribosomes
proteins and other materials emerge from
the endoplasmic reticulum in small
vesicles
[Music]
where the golgi apparatus sometimes
called the golgi body receives them
as proteins move through the golgi body
they're customized into forms that the
cell can use
the golgi body does this by folding the
proteins into usable shapes
or adding other materials onto them such
as lipids
or carbohydrates
[Music]
vacuoles are sac-like structures that
store different materials
here in this plant cell the central
vacuole stores water
going back to the animal cell you will
see an organelle called a lysosome
lysosomes are the garbage collectors
that take in damaged or worn out cell
parts
they are filled with enzymes that break
down this cellular debris
the mitochondrion is an organelle that
is the powerhouse for both animal and
plant cells
during a process called cellular
respiration the mitochondria make atp
molecules that provide the energy for
all of the cells activities
cells that need more energy have more
mitochondria
meanwhile the cell maintains its shape
through a cytoskeleton
the cytoskeleton includes the
thread-like microfilaments which are
made of protein
and microtubules which are thin hollow
tubes
some organisms such as plants that are
photoautotrophic
meaning they capture sunlight for energy
[Music]
have cells with an organelle called a
chloroplast
the chloroplast is where photosynthesis
happens it's green because it has a
green pigment called chlorophyll
plant cells also have a cell wall
outside of their cell membranes that
shape support and protect the plant cell
animal cells never have a cell wall
there are many other unique structures
that only some cells have
here are just a few
in humans for example the respiratory
tract is lined with cells that have
cilia
these are microscopic hair-like
projections that can move in waves
this feature helps trap inhaled
particles in the air and expels them
when you cough
another unique feature in some cells is
flagella
some bacteria have flagella a flagellum
is like a little tail that can help a
cell move or propel itself
the only human cell that has a flagellum
is a sperm cell
[Music]
in summary
remember eukaryotic cells are plant and
animal cells with a nucleus and membrane
enclosed organelles
while prokaryotic cells are unicellular
organisms without these things
all cells have a cell membrane cytoplasm
and genetic material
and even though only plant cells have
chloroplasts both plant and animal cells
have mitochondria
[Music]
you